Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This robot was tasked to clean up this table.
Normally, anyone who watches this series knows
that would be no big deal for any modern learning
algorithm.
Just grab it, right?
Well, not in this case, because reason number
one: several objects are tightly packed together,
and reason number two, they are too wide to
hold with the fingers.
What this means is that the robot needs to
figure out a series additional actions to
push the other pieces around and finally,
grab the correct one.
Look!
It found out that sometimes, pushing helps
grasping by making space for the fingers to
grab these objects.
This is a bit like the Roomba vacuum cleaner
robot, but even better, for clutter.
Really cool.
This robot arm works the following way: it
has an RGB-D camera, which endows it with
the ability to see both color and depth.
Now that we have this image, we have not one,
but two neural networks looking at it: one
is used to predict the utility of pushing
at different possible locations, and one for
grasping.
Finally, a decision is made as to which motion
would lead to the biggest improvement in the
state of the table.
So, what about the training process?
As you see, the speed of this robot arm is
limited, and we may have to wait for a long
time for it to learn anything useful and not
just flail around destroying other nearby
objects.
The solution includes my favorite part - training
the robot within a simulated environment,
where these commands can be executed within
milliseconds, speeding up the training process
significantly.
Our hope is always that the principles learned
within the simulation applies to reality.
Checkmark.
The simulation is also very useful to make
comparisons with other state of the art algorithms
easier.
And, do you know what the bane of many-many
learning algorithms is?
Generalization.
This means that if the technique was designed
well, it can be trained on matte looking,
wooden blocks, and it will do well when it
encounters new objects that are vastly different
in shape and appearance.
And as you see on the right, remarkably, this
is exactly the case.
Checkmark.
This takes us one step closer to learning
algorithms that can see the world around us,
interpret it, and make proper decisions to
carry out a plan.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!